you auctioned off some of your
memorabilia first of all you were smart
enough to save like things from the
gladiator but the thing that I was
fascinated one of the things you walk
shinned off you had once bought a
dinosaurs head artist from Leonardo
DiCaprio right yeah now this to me is
fascinating what is it cause it's just
been almost doubled in value since I
stole it actually I bet I mean to me
like how many dinosaur heads are there
in the world no not many
yeah we just had come being public in
private hands right this was a complete
dinosaur head yeah what type of dinosaur
was it on you again just ask me then
read and you can look it up somebody
remember Russell I bought it for my kids
yeah and you know cut myself a little
bit of slack there was a bunch of vodka
involved in that transaction so you
weren't happy that Leonardo's health you
were drinking at Leonardo's house you
guys were having a fun night yeah and
you say - Leonardo Jesus fantastic this
dinosaur I think he started the
conversation he's like I've got this one
but there's another one coming to the
market I really want so I'm trying to
sell that when I said I'll buy and when
you and so there's no negotiating he
names a price and you buy it yeah well I
said how much you want for it yeah how
much is it yeah it was pretty cool about
it just give me what I paid for it and I
think he paid like 30 or 35 grand or
some oh I thought oh I thought we were
talking even bigger money than that that
was not a very popular dinosaur oh he's
just one of those regular dynasty I mean
because it's such a it's such an unusual
item oh so then you kept it and then you
auctioned it off the diners yeah well
part of the reason for buying it is it
when I did buy it which is around about
2008 or 2009 right my kids particularly
my oldest were like fascinated they're
into dinosaurs so there's one for the
playroom a night what a dad it's awesome
did you turn down I'm talking about two
movies that I thought of that you turned
down and one of them would have been a
monster the Lord of the Rings you down
yeah and they offered you 10% yeah this
is the business now 10% of the gross a
little movie I I did the math for you to
eat your heart out one of the Rings
number one - I didn't think Peter
Jackson actually wanted me on the film
because I think he was forced into
talking
because there was a moment in time when
everybody wanted me in everything and
he's a fellow in New Zealand right you
know and so I can hear his voice and I'm
talking to him on the phone and it's
like I don't think he even knows what
I've done you know and I just knew that
my instinct was that he had somebody
else in mind which turned out to be
vegan right Viggo and you and he should
be allowed to hire the actor that he
wants you caught a vibe that the studio
is maybe forcing him to say hey we got
to get Russell Crowe for this Wow
because I did the math I don't mean to
upset you but I think you would have
gotten a hundred million dollars from
10% of that movie no more you could have
kept your dinosaur head but the rest of
the dinosaur tail and I mean it is show
business and we know that you know
there's a million actors I did this only
rarefied fuel like yourself who really
can build huge careers out of it do you
think about that every day Jesus Christ
I could have had a hundred million
dollars you're fine I forget who cares
about Vito more in the Sun never thought
about it really only in situations like
interviews with people I'll politely
find enough to add [ __ ] up for me yeah I
mean it would be nice that by an extra
hundred million dollars what does man
Howard it would not go straight and
would not you would know what to deal
with it and and and the other rapper
role famously Wolverine which would you
Jackman of course has done a brilliant
job with Riley and we agree and there's
no way I would have ever done that why
even if I'd done the film I wouldn't
have carried it through with the Grace
and the direction that Hugh gave it